Antigonish charmante petite ville de
5000 habitants en Nouvelle-Écosse c'est
là que la famille
en janvier 2016 après avoir fui la
guerre en Syrie et c'est là qui somme le
père décide de faire ce qu'il sait faire
depuis toujours du chocolat puisqu'il
avait une chocolaterie à Damas ils fonde
donc avec son fils Tarek peace by
chocolate la paix par le chocolat au
début la famille vend ses délices sur
les marchés locaux et dans cette petite
cabane de bois attenant à la maison
familiale le bouche à oreille et le
soutien de la communauté lui ouvre les
portes du succès
en septembre 2017 la chocolaterie
appuyait financièrement par un géant de
l'alimentation inaugure son usine
agrandi 4 fois depuis PS by chocolate
produit maintenant 250 variétés de
chocolat vendues dans ces magasins
d'antigonistes et dalifax et dans un
milieu de commerce au Canada
l'entreprise familiale emploie une
cinquantaine d'employés parmi lesquels
des réfugiés syriens et ukrainiens car
Tarek officiel la cause des immigrants
en plus de les embaucher il explique
dans des conférences un peu partout au
Canada les atouts précieux que
représentent l'immigration pour
l'économie canadienne
[Musique]
fête du chocolat pas la guerre le mot
paix se décline en 25 langues sur ses
tablettes dont celle-ci aux couleurs
ukrainiennes conçue symboliquement par
un Russe et un Ukrainien ou celle-là
dans la langue autochtone micmac
l'entreprise verse aussi 5% de ses
profits à des organismes comme la
Croix-Rouge canadienne ou pour la cause
de la santé mentale
[Musique]
la réputation de la chocolaterie a
rapidement dépassé les frontières de la
Nouvelle Écosse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par le Premier ministre Trudeau dans un
discours à l'ONU l'histoire de la
famille Haddad a été racontée dans un
livre humain
sorti en 2021 les chocolats de peace by
chocolate ont même voyagé jusqu'à la
station spatiale internationale
se fixe maintenant l'objectif de faire
partie des cinq plus grosses
chocolateries du Canada
toujours sous la supervision d'Islam le
patriarche chocolatier
la douceur de vivre d'Antigonish petite
ville de nouvelles Écosse ou une famille
syrienne de Damas a pu refaire sa vie
avec succès et c'est Catherine François
Radio-Canada Antigonish